Well let's bring it up, let's roll one dice one time, we get a five, let's roll
it again, we got a three. You can keep rolling it and we see what we get, we
don't want to do this 100 times, so let's just change this and select 100. Now
we'll roll one dice, 100 times. So by chance, by simulation, we get a lot more
6s than 5s. Let's try it again. Our distribution is looking pretty uniform.
Let's try a thousand. Here it looks even more uniform, so the more you roll the
die. One two three four five and six all have an equal chance of getting
selected and so our distribution is uniform. In this case our sample size was
one, so we don't really have sample means right now. So essentially, the
standard error is just the population standard deviation divided by the square
root of 1, which is just the population standard deviation. So when we're taking
samples of size 1, we're just drawing members of the actual population. And so
then when we graph our distribution of sample means then we're really just
graphing our actual population so we'll get a distribution that's approximately
equal to the distribution of the population, which is uniform since we just have
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and 6.